معنا لمناقشة الأثر الصحي
لهذا كله ، شكراً لدكتورة جينيفر جونتر دكتور
جونتر لانضمامك إلينا ،
ووفقًا لـ Guttmacher ، فإن واحدة من بين كل
أربع نساء في الولايات المتحدة
ستخضع للإجهاض
في سن 45. فماذا يعني هذا الحكم
أن
ربع النساء والفتيات الأمريكيات ،
نعم ، هذا يعني الفقر ، نحن نعلم أن
عدم القدرة على الإجهاض
يزيد من احتمالية أن
تعيش في فقر ، وهذا يعني زيادة
خطر وفيات الأمهات بسبب الإجهاض غير القانوني
من
مضاعفات أثناء الحمل ، وهو ما
يمكننا الآن "  نظرًا لوجود
نشاط قلبي للجنين ووفيات الأمهات بسبب
مضاعفات الحمل ، فهذا يعني أيضًا أن
الأشخاص الذين تعرضوا للإجهاض قد يجدون
صعوبة في الوصول إلى الأدوية
لعلاج ذلك أو الحمل خارج الرحم وقد
يؤثر ذلك حتى على وسائل منع الحمل ، فهي
بعيدة المدى ومدمرة.
الحديث
عن الحمل المعقد أه المضاعفات
مسائل صحية ما
معنى الحكم؟  هؤلاء المرضى
جيدًا ، فهذا يعني
أننا نعلم في العديد من الولايات أن الأطباء لن
يكونوا قادرين على فعل أي شيء لأن العديد من
الولايات ليس لديها استثناء صحي ، ولكن
حتى لو فعلوا ذلك ، فهم غير قابل للتفسير ،
فأنت تعلم أنني كنت في موقف شخصي
مع مريضة كانت
تعاني من حالة طبية خطيرة
وشعر أطباؤها أن صحتها
ستتحسن إذا لم تكن حاملاً
وكان لدينا قانون لا يمكننا فيه إجراء
عمليات الإجهاض في منشأتنا الطبية
وكان علي الاتصال بالسياسي الذي كتب
القانون في المنزل للحصول على إذن ،
أعرف أه شخص لديه
مشكلة كبيرة في الحمل حيث
كان دماغ الجنين
ينمو بالفعل خارج الجمجمة
،
لم يكن هناك طريقة لعيش هذا الطفل
وحصلت الأم على  الإجهاض
الذي ستُجبر أمه في بعض
هذه الولايات مثل جنوب داكوتا أو
أوكلاهوما مجبرًا على حمل الطفل إلى
المدى
الصحيح والآن تخيل أن تقول
أنك حامل ، والآن
لديك كل هؤلاء الأشخاص يلامسون
بطنك و  يسألك أنك تعرف عن
طفلك الذي تعلم أنه
سيولد ليموت ولكن تخيل أنك إذا
تعرضت لمضاعفات في الحمل ، قل أنك تعانين من ارتفاع ضغط الدم حقًا في الأسبوع 32
ثم نقوم بذلك ، نريد أن نولئك
مبكرًا ولكن هذا الجنين  سوف تموت
عند ولادتها ، فهل أجرينا الآن عملية
إجهاض ،
أعني أن القوانين حقًا شيء آخر غير قابل للتفسير
وأنت تطرقت إلى هذا الأمر ،
ولا أعرف ما إذا كان الناس يفهمون في كثير من
الأحيان أنه يجب
على المرأة التي
تُجهض أن تذهب للحصول على عملية إجهاض  لقد
أوضحت أن هذا
صحيح تمامًا ، لذا في بعض الأحيان عندما
يتعرض الأشخاص للإجهاض يكون لديهم ما
نطلق عليه اسمك تعرف الإجهاض الفائت أو
غير مكتمل ، وبالتالي تبدأ العملية
ولكنها لا تنتهي ولذا فإننا نصف
الأدوية التي
نستخدمها للإجهاض الدوائي  كانت هناك
بالفعل نساء يبلغن عبر الإنترنت ،
لقد رأيت تقارير على Facebook عنهن
يحضرن إلى الصيدليات كما تعلم
يسألن عن وصفتهن الطبية ويتم
رفضهن لأن الصيدلي وا
كانت قلقة من إجهاضهن